[Musique]
il
aujourd'hui on va parler de la maison
connectée on va parler de shiro mi
janvier dans une maison à paris pour
parler effectivement de la maison
connectée de firmi et vous allez voir il
ya ceux qui sont vraiment intéressants
alors ce qu'on va faire c'est que là on
est tout en bas dans le sous sol
il ya des pieds en dehors et une grande
fête à l'extérieur
voyez petite maison cause ils sont pas
mal ici d'ailleurs et the le petit ping
pong
alors voyons va faire le tour de la
maison comme ça je vous montre un peu la
maison connectée par chirurgie après si
vous voulez on sera l'irlande car moins
10 morceaux de piano puis au mitard et
vit son marché a pas très longtemps il
ya plein plein plein plein de produits
de la marque xiaomi pressaient les
smartphones en a beaucoup parlé on a
aussi parlé de la trottinette électrique
on a parlé de montres collecter extra
man qui que ce soit elles alimenteront
n'a pas eu pas mal de choses mais y'a
plein de produits qui vont arriver pour
la maison connectée
franchement ça déchire alors y voir
notre quoi manger c'est plutôt pas mal
mais c'est pas le but aujourd'hui on va
parler un petit peu de chez au mit donc
ça vous colle et c'est toute la gamme de
smartphones que ce soit le biais de
l'aid qu'on a vu quand on était à et
demi à deux quand on était à madrid cet
été
le mx3 le 1008 lepoko phone mx2 est ce
vrai minaude 6 renmin autres 5 raid me
s2 rémy 6 à une gamme qui est extra
plex pour ça on en a beaucoup parlé sur
la chaîne on va continuer et ça s'arrête
vous avez aussi d'un monde connecté me
bank 3 on a déjà parlé on a déjà du
canton étaient aussi à milan on a la
macif la stratos deux viaducs as
possible
on a différents écouteurs oui c'est
vraiment une gamme qui est extrêmement
complète on a aussi les power banques
pour venir charger ses smartphones mais
ça s'arrête pas là parce que vous avez
aussi la bbox avec google caste sur
laquelle vous avez accès à youtube
netflix j'en passe et compagnie donc ça
aussi c'est pareil c'est franchement
connue mais ça ne s'arrête pas là pour
plus lorsque vous avez aussi la caméra à
360 degrés ça c'est une petite caméra
connectés qui vous envoie des
notifications vous pouvez piloter que ce
soit pour la surveillance de votre
maison la maison connectée c'est bien
évidemment de la vidéosurveillance avec
des capteurs quelques temps sur les
portes alarme mais ça s'arrête pas là
tant mieux c'est carrément monté encore
je suis au premier avec la chaîne si
telle avait chaussé sur le première
étage vous allez voir
salariale pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas est ce qu'on peut te présenter ouais
je m'appelle niane réussir le défi c'est
ce dernier en france tel monsieur celle
du français
c'est ça bon alors est ce que tu peux
nous expliquer ce qu'on fait ce soir ce
qui se passe maison connectée objections
de collecter shiomi c'est important
qu'on rende vraiment l'unifier tous les
objets sur milite dans un seul
environnement que cela à peu près le
même en dire le
les conditions des aides d'accord ok ça
qui est fait donc ça en proposant un
large de choix des produits connectés
pour mettre vraiment un smartphone
d'accord si on rire et c'est important
pour le démontrer ce côté là parce que
c'est vrai qu'ils ont mis en france et
beaucoup connu pour les smartphones et
énormément quoi smartphone est aussi la
nive en trois mots de connections n'ai
vu la trottinette à d'état écrit qu'il
ya vrai gros succès en tout cas beaucoup
beaucoup d'engouement mais chez omidyar
catalogue qui énorme catalogue qui est
nombre qu'est ce qu'on trouve un peu
pour la maison vraiment compter la
maison sont l'éclairage sur la sincérité
nous les smartphones c'est important la
chorale formant de connecter à tous les
objets même créer de l'interaction très
objet le corps auquel exemple très
simple c'est que un bracelet jolie et
qui avec une lampe joly ils
confronteront mendiants sommeil léger
c'est un livre de lumière d'accord le
sommeil profond savez en conclure en
lumière d'accord qu'on sait c'est ça que
l'on peut parler démontré dans un
magasin ni encore moins dans un bureau
donc l'endroit idéal c'est dans un
maison et on arrive typiquement dans la
pièce connecter à savoir que vous avez
un capteur qui étaient positionnées ici
capteur de présence qui va pouvoir
activer une alarme qui va servir
également de veilleuses qui va servir
aussi d'enceinte puisque vous avez du
son qui sort et schumi s'est dit
pourquoi pas lui qui dans les deux sens
donc si vous voulez mettre de la musique
en même temps par ce biais là vous
pouvez vous avez la radio c'est plutôt
cool vous avez également les ampoules
connectés shiomi un peu comme ce qu'on
peut retrouver chez philips vous pouvez
complètement les paramétrer 16 millions
de couleurs créer des scènes ce que vous
voulez ça c'est cool
et vous avez forcément ici les capteurs
de présence à ce que vous allez ouvrir
une porte ça va avoir une action
directement ici là l'action c'est
d'allumer la lumière et lorsque jose
celui là normalement se doit déclencher
la lande qui au mieux détailler en
france encore au mois de mai c'est pas
bête il 21 au 22 mai comment savoir ils
vendent mais très bien ouais a très très
bien il quand le produit d'arrivée
beaucoup de lancements beaucoup de
nouveautés là j'ai vu le loup mx3 qui
peut encore arriver en france mais
probablement début 2019 ça se passe bien
vous êtes contents de l'implantation il
ya un nouveau magasin j'ai vu aussi au
forum mondial qui a ouvert sa ok c'est
ça qui est important pour l'eau ce qui
est intéressant c'est que vous restez
tout vraiment de proposer de produits
attribué accessible à tout le monde
au nom des valeurs qui est
qui recommence tout le monde oui
pourquoi pas
c'est chiant pour moi c'est une question
de temps on va y arriver ouais on va
dire franchement bien parti ils sont
envoyés en retour qu'on est content
d'aller retours qu'on à l'engouement
autour de la marque voit la marque en
tout cas est vraiment placé aujourd'hui
en termes de smartphones a minima
maintenant le smartphone ya problème
encore entre de l'étape pour faire
connaître toutes les solutions mais il
tellement de choses comment ça se fait
que j'ai omis se positionne sur autant
de marchés différents
encore une fois je reviens sur la petit
slogan innovation quand on the way
vraiment on pense que l ambiance est pas
que le petit pigeon qui tout le monde
arabe a rassuré sur son voisin téléphone
on est on n'est pas rentré dans les
phases de démocratisation raconte une
caméra 360
une pale ans rédacteur il va connecter
que les gens ne connaissent pas encore
sur un produit pour moi et ça ça va
c'est pour nous c'est une
démocratisation de la technologie
auxquelles il est important qu'on doit
donc rendre les technologies accessibles
à tous
[Musique]
dans la maison qu'ils ont été choisis
vous avez aussi le petit rhône qui est
juste la petite robe de faire voler
uniquement en intérieur si vous mettez
un extérieur avec le vent ça valait gt
ça marchera pas du tout tu tombes
arrivée dans la salle de bain là c'est
plutôt cool
on a déjà vu la brosse à dents si vous
vous souvenez on s'adore par ultrasons
ça vibre hyper hyper fort ça on l'avait
vu un milan qui vous lie plus loin dans
la santé connectés shiomi vous avez le
ps personne qui est juste là ça fait une
éternité que je suis pas pesé je pense
qu'elle ne marche pas
et en dehors la salle de bain vous
pouvez aussi ensuite venir faire des
parties sur écran géant
le vidéoprojecteur qui était présente et
qu'on a vu à milan qu'est vraiment en
particulier sur vidéo proches et vous
avez en main une focale hyper courte
vous le mettez vraiment très très très
près de votre mur du coup vous n'êtes
pas obligé d'avoir un recul de dengue la
différence de certains vidéoprojecteur
donc ça franchement c'est hyper hyper
hyper appréciable on va de plus en plus
de conducteurs il espère pouvoir tourner
la première boutique
si on me suis allé faire un petit tour
je regrettais c'est qu'elle est pas
encore beaucoup de profs qui est arrivé
en france là pour le coup ça a changé et
c'est franchement énorme
il ya même un produit je pense que vous
ne saurez jamais ce que c'est c'est ce
truc là
à votre avis je vous laisse marquer en
commentaire je vous laisse quelques
secondes
regardez le un regard des le à votre
avis qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être
ça c'est un truc qui hallucinant
personne ne devinera franchement je fais
ma main à couper que vous n'allez pas
deviner allez je vais attendre quelques
secondes vous regardez bien de tous les
côtés marc et m'a tout de suite en
commentaire vous mettez la limite la
pause voulu marquer lui aussi de vous
verrez vous serez forcément tromper
vous donne la réponse cet objet la selle
a retiré les moustiques de votre
intérieur
ce qui fait que les moustiques viennent
la danse un pièges à moustique est finie
les moustiques ça franchement je m'en
procurer un très très rapidement du mois
pour l'été prochain parce que les
moustiques je n'en peux plus et pour
avoir un air hyper sain et sauf
c'est assez dur à dire on a un
purificateur d'air chaud et humide donc
ça c'est aussi franchement hyper cool on
avec fred qui est le directeur général
dg de modelabs alors moi de là c'est le
distributeur de produits chimiques n'est
pas effectivement aux autres entre
autres oui je mourir mis en place et
dont sony pas mal alors on est ce soir
dans une soirée où on visite un
appartement connecter avec vale de rang
d'icône et enfin beaucoup de produits
connectés survie c'est quoi votre rôle
vous bagdad faut-il comprendre
rapidement un nom des distributeurs de
smartphones de jamy et à trois mois on a
ouvert la catégorie younsi et
accessoires un peu plus en général
yes et comme on les a ouverts en dernier
on a voulu proposer un petit peu aux
clients après ce de découvrir en fait
l'environnement parce qu'on a peu
d'occasions finalement
de les découvrir et donc c'est un peu
pour ça qu'on a présenté dans 26 l'offre
comme tu as pu le voir par un peu un peu
de vos écrans des petits des petits
balance connectée des petites brosses à
dents connecter des lumières connecter
un peu tout cet environnement qui est
franchement exceptionnel moyens
exceptionnels aussi il faut le dire ça
plutôt cool alors vous vous intervenez
pour la distribution c'est à dire que
fait le lien en gros entre autres chez
tommy et les revendeurs il s'agit pas de
passif est tombé entre le fabricants et
les distributeurs qu'on connaît les
rites et leur que ce soit le e-commerce
que ce soit auchan carrefour fnac
boulanger darty etc
bon voilà pourtant données sont
collectées le chiot me dites moi ce que
vous en pensiez vous tous ces objets
connectés est ce qu'il pourrait vous
intéresser
je vous invite à marquer mais surtout ça
en commentaire me dire si vous avez déjà
un smartphone de chauny si vous avez des
objets connectés
je pense notamment à lagny bon 3
pourquoi pas même le scooter électrique
de chimie forcément un objet connecté
votre il fait partie de l'écosystème de
la marque ou maquettes ou sans
commentaire bien évidemment vous invite
à faire une chose c'est un vous abonner
comme ça vous suivrez toute l'actu et
toutes les nouveautés qui ont beaucoup
parlé de chauny parce que croyez moi là
dedans cette fin d'année ça va se calmer
un peu et en 2019
ça n'al'air fond est bien évidemment à
suivre est différente playlist pour
choisir notamment votre smartphone et
tout ce que vous voulez voilà soyez
sages vous embrasse pour les soins de
haut puis moi je suis allé faire un
petit peu mieux la coupe à la mi temps